DEFINITELY A SHOWDOWN BETWEEN
THE U.S. SENATE AND THE
PRESIDENT ON THE ZTE ISSUE.
>> Bret: WILL FOLLOW IT.
THANK YOU.
THE MAN WHO WROTE LAST WEEK'S
REPORT ABOUT THE FBI'S
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL SCANDAL
WAS ON CAPITOL HILL THIS
AFTERNOON TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
AND DEFEND HIS CONCLUSIONS.
ALONG WITH HIM, THE FBI DIRECTOR
WHO IS PROMISING TO CHANGE
THINGS AND HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE SHOWS US WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> I WANT YOU TO REOPEN THE
INVESTIGATION.
>> SENIOR REPUBLICAN
SENATOR DRILL DOWN ON THE
ANTI-TRUMP TEXT MESSAGES BETWEEN
FBI AGENT PETER STRZOK AND FBI
LAWYER LISA PAGE.
THE 2016 MEETING WAS ABOUT A
"INSURANCE POLICY" DISCUSSED IN
THEN FBI DEPUTY DIRECTOR
ANDREW MCCABE'S OFFICE.
STRZOK TEXTED ABOUT THE MEETING.
>> YOU ASKED MR. McCABE.
>> HE SAID HE DID NOT RECALL.
>> SENATOR GRAHAM SAID IT REEKED
OF POLITICAL BIAS AND THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S CONCLUSIONS
ARE OFF-BASE.
>> I'M GLAD YOU FOUND WHAT YOU
FOUND.
I'M NOT BUYING THAT THE CLINTON
EMAIL INVESTIGATION WAS ON THE
UP AND UP.
>> FIRST PUBLIC TESTIMONY FROM
INSPECTOR GENERAL MICHAEL
HOROWITZ AND FBI DIRECTOR
CHRISTOPHER WRAY DIVIDED ALONG
PARTY LINES.
>> DIRECTOR RAY HAS A MESS TO
CLEAN UP.
I THINK HE PROBABLY KNOWS THAT.
>> THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FOUND
NO EVIDENCE OF POLITICAL BIAS IN
THE FBI'S INVESTIGATION.
OF SECRETARY CLINTON OR IN THE
DECISION NOT TO PURSUE CRIMINAL
CHARGES.
>> HOROWITZ TESTIFIED HE'S BEEN
ASKED TO INVESTIGATE JAMES COMEY
ASKED TO INVESTIGATE JAMES COME
COMEY.
>> WE RECEIVED A REFERRAL ON
THAT FROM THE FBI.
WE ARE HANDLING THAT REFERRAL
AND WE WILL ISSUE A REPORT WHEN
THE MATTER IS COMPLETE.
>> DEMOCRATS PRESSED ON LEAKS IN
THE FALL OF 2016 FORMER
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR
RUDY GIULIANI.
>> CAN YOU ASSURE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THERE ARE NO ONGOING
LEAKS FROM ANY OFFICE OF THE FBI
TO RUDOLPH GIULIANI?
TO GO I'M AWARE OF ANY.
WE ARE AGGRESSIVELY
INVESTIGATING A NUMBER OF LEAKS
EVEN AS WE SPEAK.
>> BASED ON THE FINDINGS, FBI
DIRECTOR SAID HALF A DOZEN
EMPLOYEES COULD BE DISCIPLINED
BUT HE EMPHASIZED THE MISTAKES
AND BAD JUDGMENT WERE LIMITED.
>> THIS REPORT IS FOCUSED ON A
SPECIFIC SET OF EVENTS BACK IN
2016 AND A SMALL NUMBER OF FBI
EMPLOYEES CONNECTED WITH THOSE
EVENTS.
SATISFIED.
>> LET'S REMEMBER WHO THAT SMALL
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES WAS, THE
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI, DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI, LEADER OF
BOTH THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION AND THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
>> INSPECTOR GENERAL WILL
TESTIFY FOR A SECOND DAY IN
FRONT OF TWO HOUSE PANELS
TOMORROW IN A SEPARATE
DEVELOPMENT AFTER MONTHS OF
PRESSURE, THE LAWYER FOR FBI
AGENT PETER STRZOK HAS
CONFIRMED THAT HE WILL
VOLUNTARILY TESTIFY BEFORE THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND